how is the media viewing russia's war in
ukraine
competing narratives fight for coverage
in print on air and online
so are we getting an accurate picture of
what's happening in the conflict this is
inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
mohammad jim zhum it's often said that
the first casualty of war is the truth
and the media is the battleground for
competing narratives on russia's
invasion of ukraine images of
destruction and civilian suffering
dominate headlines worldwide but both
sides accuse each other of
disinformation
take for example the russian airstrike
that destroyed a maternity hospital in
mary uphol last week at least three
people died in what western leaders
called a war crime but russia accused
ukraine of staging the attack in a now
deleted tweet the russian embassy in
london accused this woman of being a
so-called crisis actor who was paid to
play a victim
the ukrainian and russian presidents
project different images of themselves
velodimizulinsky gives daily updates on
social media dressed in green army
t-shirts that's helped to boost his
popularity among ukrainians to nearly 90
percent
in contrast russia's vladimir putin is
mostly seen in official videos sitting
far away from government advisers
an editor on russian state tv was fined
for interrupting a news broadcast with
her anti-war message but russian media
mostly repeat the kremlin's message of
what it calls a special military
operation
journalists who call it a war or
invasion face 15 years in prison
independent outlets have been shut down
facebook and instagram are blocked
58 percent of russians support the
invasion according to a survey last week
all right let's bring in our guests in
western ukraine olga to karaoke a
ukrainian journalist and a non-resident
fellow at the center for european policy
analysis
in london nikolai petrov a senior
research fellow at the russia and
eurasia program at the chatham house
think tank
and in berlin marcus zeener a professor
of journalism at the university of
applied sciences a warm welcome to you
all and thanks so much for joining us
today on inside story olga let me start
with you today from your vantage point
in western ukraine do you believe that
most of the world is now getting an
accurate picture of what's happening in
the conflict
well you know it's very difficult to
generalize right we cannot uh speak
about the whole world there are specific
differences in every region well as a
journalist i'm speaking to many media
from different countries just today i
had interviews with you know media from
south korea to india australia uh israel
and
united arab emirates and i can also see
the difference in the kinds of questions
that i'm getting and you know the
concerns that are different in different
countries and the accents that are some
sometimes put differently uh as a
journalist i can say that you know my
colleagues are doing an amazing job here
in ukraine trying to report and what is
happening from ukraine uh in extremely
difficult circumstances four journalists
have been killed so far in ukraine i
happen to know two of them personally
you know it breaks my heart that my
colleagues have to go through such
enormous risks because russians are
targeting civilians are deliberately
targeting journalists with this call to
seminate terror and with the scope
apparently to prevent the world from
knowing what is happening here to
intimidate media and journalists from
you know reporting from the ground in
ukraine so i want to commend those
courageous colleagues who despite
everything continue reporting from
ukraine from the hot spots such as cave
parking mariopol and you know i just
want to really stress how important this
information is and
unbiased reporting is especially in this
era of so many fakes and this
information coming from the russian side
nikola i want to turn the viewers
attention specifically to russia right
now and i want to ask you about russians
watching or reading or listening to the
news within russia what are they hearing
how different is what they are hearing
or seeing or reading from what most of
the rest of the world is reading or
seeing or hearing about the conflict in
ukraine
i would say that the russians are
getting very
sensitive and limited uh picture and
images uh from ukraine
uh
shown by uh state's
own channels and as you became snow
almost all independent media
uh have been shut up and
even social networks are closed in some
cases but the problem i see is not so
much connected with the fact that uh
there is a lack of information of course
this is ukraine this is name a country
there are a lot of personal connections
uh which could somehow compensate the
problem i see is connected with the fact
that there is a kind of psychological
barrier not all the russian government
uh prefers to
uh call it not the war but the limited
military operation
but the vision majority of russians
do have in their minds is that their
army is liberating uh brothers
ukrainians from nazis from nazi
government and psychologically it's much
more comfortable to keep this vision
than to think that
your state your government are
committing
war crimes and you should do something
for yourself
we do have a lot of
cases when relatives are given calls
from ukraine and they are not
understood by their direct relatives in
marshall
marcus i want to talk for a moment about
this study in contrast between the image
that's being projected by ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky versus the
image that's being projected by russian
president vladimir putin zielinski is
often seen in these social media videos
unshaven he's wearing green army
t-shirts uh sometimes he's among his
advisors other times he's out on the
streets uh then you see putin and it's
very different these are these official
videos where often he's alone or seated
very far away even from close advisors
has that helped zielinski and if so how
much
yeah in fact it has helped him uh quite
quite a bit if you look at how the
narrative has been shaped and framed
from the ukrainian side i think they
they do it very well i'm not saying they
do it um just always by purpose but i
think they know how to play social media
they know how to convey a narrative and
a certain message
and i think what we're seeing here is
basically a new a kind of modern version
of the david against goliath kind of
story you have this um
this
ukraine country of 40 million
fighting an overwhelming military power
russia and uh you have here this guy
volody mirzielenski standing up against
uh against putin and i think the images
are really telling on the one hand you
have putin sitting on a long table
but kind of being untouchable
and
is basically behind the walls of the
kremlin while on the other side you have
celensky who is somebody who is
just among among his people and uh he's
looking tired he's looking worn he's
just dressed in a military shirt uh he's
not making things up and uh so when it
comes to authenticity
i think that's uh clearly on the side of
the ukrainians
olga what do ukrainians by and large
think of how president zielinski has
been presenting himself before and
throughout this conflict how much has he
been able to transform public opinion
through his style of wartime leadership
well we are seeing from the polls that
the popularity and the support of
citizens uh you know to president
zielenski has grown sharply uh
recently a poll it was conducted that
indicates that about 90 percent of
ukrainians support the actions of their
president before the war that percentage
was around 25
so he's showing himself you know as a
true leader of his people a very a
person who is close to his citizens who
you know doesn't keep a distance who's
speaking to them directly recording
video statements several times a day
speaking in the language that people
understand addressing not just
ukrainians but in fact addressing
russians in their own language calling
on russian mothers you know to uh take
their sons away from ukraine calling on
russians to go to protest thanking
russian journalists or
propaganda media workers
or former workers for standing up and
saying the truth
so you know zalensky is communicating
very efficiently and he's rallying the
people around him but i would also say
that you know it's not just the zelinski
who is leading the country and who is
kind of inspiring ukrainians it's also
the other way around its ukrainians who
are with their incredible courage and
determination are inspiring zelensky to
leave this country and you know to speak
for all these people and we hear that
also in his speeches in just today's
speech at the us congress he said again
that i'm speaking here on behalf of the
ukrainian people and this is something
that you know i think a lot of
ukrainians kind of share and they
appreciate that that he's not detached
from his people he's speaking for the
whole country and the whole country is
speaking in one voice
nikolai there are surveys that have been
done in russia that suggest that a
majority of russians support the
invasion of ukraine
but can this polling actually be trusted
is it independent
uh well there are no independent
pollings uh uh these days in russia
first and second
we should have in mind that uh during
the war it's hard to
wait for uh well uh correct offenses in
many cases due to different reasons
the problem is that uh nevertheless i do
think that majority of russians
being somehow brainwashed being strongly
focused on the fact that
their country
did weigh and does play now the role of
a kind of best turn against
fascists against nazis and this is how
the story is presented by russian media
well uh they do support uh their
presidents uh and so in my view we can
uh discuss whether this one can be
measured in 70 or 60 percent like
different poles are peeling us but
generally speaking majority of russians
especially if not to have in mind that
the active and very loud minority who
were protesting against the war and who
are still protesting against the way in
spite of their
police pressure
many of them did leave from the country
marcus you know president putin has for
quite a while now several years he's had
this reputation as a wizard of
information warfare he has a reputation
as someone who's successfully been able
to weaponize social media and and other
types of information is it surprising to
you to see
how this is playing out thus far
um yes you're right he has successfully
actually
interfered in elections uh he has tried
to turn public opinion uh also in
germany also in the united states
uh but he's failing here and um i think
one of the things that probably are not
playing out very well for the russians
is
the use of a certain uh language a
certain narrative let's take a look for
instance the use of fascism and nazis i
mean uh putin was saying well we have to
go into ukraine to kind of denatify
ukraine i mean the the president of
ukraine is of jewish origin so how can
you actually be a nazi i mean you see a
distortion of all of the terms
and the notions uh we used to know and i
think this narrative is not playing into
his hands now at the same time
um from a western perspective probably
we can see that this way it doesn't
really mean that uh russians are
going along with that
i think he still has a lot of support
and i'm not really sure that
the majority of russians are looking
through this maneuver
olga you spoke in your previous answer
about the fact that from your
perspective it's not just zielinski
president zielinski who's been inspiring
the people but it's also the people of
ukraine who've been inspiring president
zielinski
i want to ask you if you think that in
the lead-up to the invasion in the
lead-up to the war if the reporting
from foreign countries was mostly
accurate do you think that ukrainian
voices were really being listened to
no i i don't think so in fact you know
and this of course varies from one
country to another but in some uh
you know major uh players in some major
countries of the european union i can
speak for italy because i speak italian
and i can monitor the information space
there but i know it is also the case in
germany france in some other big
countries very often you know people who
go in the media speak about ukraine and
russia
those experts those analysts those uh
you know
geopolitics experts they have never set
foot to ukraine and they very often
describe the situation and spoke about
ukraine in through you know through the
russian optics using some sort of
russian imperialist narrative about
ukraine uh very often denying an agency
to ukrainians it was very rare and it is
still quite rare in some countries to
hear ukrainian voices in mainstream
media although you know there have been
some improvements since the war started
and there have been more attention paid
to what ukrainians actually have to say
but i think you know a big problem is
that in the last eight years since
russia first invaded in 2014 very few in
the west listen to what ukrainians were
saying there very few listen to
ukrainians warnings that if you know
putin is not stopped if russia is not
punished with really strong sanctions if
there is no strong reaction from the
west putin will not stop and will only
escalate his aggression now the same
people well some of them at least you
know who didn't listen to ukrainians and
other central and eastern europeans and
people from the baltic states are
finally admitting that we were right but
isn't it too late
nikolai you know we've spoken a lot
about the the clampdown on on
independent media outlets uh in in
russia uh just this week there there was
an incident there was an interruption of
a news broadcast on russian television
by an editor who shared an anti-war
message and i want to ask you if you
think that
this would have made any kind of an
impact with with viewers who have really
been enjoyed to the official russian
line about the invasion by people who've
only been watching russian television
and that particular narrative would
would they
have have found this surprising would it
have helped to change perceptions in any
way
i think that was very brave reaction
from the side of marina senior
is her name and of course it's very
important uh not only to demonstrate
that a lot of journalists and some of
them uh did resign in course of last
weeks a lot of journalists uh do not
take seriously the russian they do
uh demonstrate uh working for
russian television channels and somehow
we can send a signal
to those who are watching television but
as i did already say the problem i see
is not that much connected with the fact
that there is a lack of alternative
information of alternative channels it's
possible to find almost everything in
internet these days there is
psychological defense a lot of russians
who prefer to keep
in order not to feel themselves in in an
extremely uncomfortable position and
it's changing it's changing not only is
you to create appearances of some
persons not due to the fact that a lot
of celebrities are openly seeing
publicly staying against the world but
it's due to the fact that russians to
feel in their
usual life that the situation
is changing to worse and that's why they
should change their minds they should
change their opinion this means that
putin is very much limited in time he
should do something in order to uh well
stop the situation uh deteriorating for
him inside the country and this means
that well he does have another two or
three weeks uh to transform the
situation to his family for he is
capable to do this
marcus for those who believe that
president zielinski uh and therefore
ukraine uh that they're winning this
information war
does that also create a perception that
ukraine may be doing better on the
actual battlefield than they are
well i mean the uh if you if you believe
what military experts are saying then um
i think um ukraine is doing very well uh
on the ground when it comes to making uh
making the advances
uh hard for for the russian military so
i think that's that's a fact uh and
that's not really that much um
influenced by
by the media appearance
um i have to admit actually from from
from perspective as
the a professor i mean
what is a little bit striking it was
probably a matter of concern is the fact
that journalism doesn't really play that
much of a role right now we get
footage we get
videos directly fed in actually into our
our social media and twitter accounts
which come
right out from the president's palace in
kiev or right from from from other
places without any journalistic kind of
assessment and orientation i mean this
is not a new problem but it's playing
out here quite quite a bit so we are
seeing things and we have to uh we have
to make up ourselves what we are seeing
it's it's missing this context marcus
i'm sorry to interrupt you but may i ask
you you bring up an interesting point
may i ask is it actually harder now than
it was a few years back to to pass off
false information or faked videos i mean
has online verification of footage you
know has that entire
the entirety of that been strengthened
of late
absolutely it has become so difficult
and
um as much as we sympathize with one
side or the other i think uh for
journalists they are required to take
the footage and to check it and to try
to figure out whether this is true or
not um by the way let please allow me
just to say one word on to olga i mean
um be having been a journalist and still
am a journalist myself and having
reported from moscow i can tell you that
at least the german media is uh
reporting very critically actually uh
about russia which is always uh
uh
was a was a very um
disputed fact so i i i think uh when it
comes to russia uh german media is very
critical and uh and and not the not pro
pro putin
olga from your perspective how prominent
a role have disinformation fighters
online been been playing in all of this
well you know um i think with this war
many people in the west who
underestimated the
prominence and the impact and you know
the scope of russian propaganda and
disinformation i finally starting to
realize it
uh and the case in point is uh with the
that pregnant woman from mario paul
mariana uh who you know was filmed by
associated press photographers after the
bombing of the hospital and then we have
seen the attempts by uh several russian
embassies abroad on twitter to smear her
to say that she was a crisis actor that
she was wearing makeup and she wasn't
actually pregnant in fact
and you know twitter took down those
posts and we've seen the new footage
from mario paul several days after that
that she actually gave birth to a baby
and i also was in touch with her
relatives who confirmed that they sent
me the photos and i think you know for
many uh that case was something an
eye-opener because many people didn't
believe that russians could be lying
that you know that much and these are
russian officials and the russian
officials are lying on the highest level
and there is a russian propaganda in
this information machine it consists of
so many layers you know starting from
the troll and bot forms on the social
media such as uh twitter and facebook
and uh you know russian state media
inside russia uh russian state media
that are uh you know broadcasting for
their audiences abroad such as rt and
sputnik and a lot of also conspiracy uh
propaganda this information websites in
many many countries that sometimes do
not you know spread just news about
russia or ukraine they might be sharing
anti-vaccine disinformation or
different conspiracy theories and i hope
you know this war is uh kind of brings
more awareness and on the level of the
of the governments in the world the
level of the media also who are
bombarded by this disinformation and
sometimes find it hard to uh you know uh
establish what is right and what is
wrong what is true and what is not olga
so if i'm sorry
i'm sorry to interrupt if i could just
ask you we just have about a minute and
a half left but i also want to ask you
the way that it's been playing out this
far has it defied your expectations
about how online warfare typically plays
out
well uh you know
this was not something new for me
because i've been researching this
information for more than two years my
actually career in journalism brought me
to this because i encountered as a
journalist so much this information and
how it actually affected people's lives
on the ground
so i started to research it and i think
you know this is also a goal now for
many journalists across the world and
for many media to focus on that more to
understand how this information works
and what a real life impact it can have
and how it can also fuel wars because
eight years of propaganda and russian tv
contributed to this war as well
all right well we have uh run out of
time so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests olga tokariuk nikolai
petrov and marcus zener
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad zhum and the whole team here
bye for now
[Music]
you